[Music]
did you realize that the last class born
in the 90s will be graduating in 2017 if
you were born in that amazing decade
this is going to make you feel old we're
just starting to realize that we're
adults now so today we're celebrating
our childhood with memories from the 90s
and early 2000s do you remember what was
the link between a pencil and a cassette
watched this video to find out if this
is your first time visiting our channel
don't forget to subscribe to the thing
and give this video a big thumbs up
today we're showing you ten pictures
that will make you feel old old cell
phones nowadays we can't live without
our cell phones we sleep with them eat
with them go to the bathroom with them
people are so obsessed with this
technology that being separated from
your smartphone became a new fear it's
called nomophobia an abbreviation for no
mobile phone phobia but decades ago
owning a cell phone was not as much fun
as it is now sending a text message took
so much time because you had to press a
number up to four times just to type out
one letter one of our first smartphones
in the 2000s had a keyboard and we were
amazed by this it is far from the
touchscreens we have now and do you
remember the Nokia phones nowadays when
our iPhone falls on the floor the screen
breaks but in the 90s when a Nokia fell
on the floor it almost broke the floor
but there is at least one thing that we
like about cell phones in the 90s they
were so difficult to use that we were
happier without them kids didn't have a
smartphone but we used different ways to
talk to our friends in class we shared
messages written on a piece of paper and
we were so embarrassed when a teacher
found it and read it in front of
everyone else did that ever happen to
you tell us what happened in the
comments below
Tamagotchis we now have to go to school
during the week work during the weekends
sleep eight hours a night and try to
maintain a social life we can't help but
think that we were so lucky when we were
kids life was so much easier when all we
had to think about was our Tamagotchi in
the 2000s we used to press three
different buttons to take care of this
little digital creature we had to feed
them when they were hungry play mini
games with them to make them happy and
scold them when they didn't behave well
Tamagotchi players started the game with
a baby and the pet grew up to a child a
teenager
if we took good enough care of them it
might seem simple but it was much more
difficult to do than what kids nowadays
might think when you forgot your
Tamagotchi for a day he could become
sick or even die at least this made us
appreciate much more what our moms did
for us we understand what parenting was
but with this digital pet we proudly
claimed that we could take care of a
real animal can you believe that our
Tamagotchis have been dead for more than
10 years oh my we have been such
horrible parents MSN Messenger us
smartphone owners aged 18 to 24 cent on
average more than 2,000 text messages
every month and almost seventy every day
but in the 2000s we didn't have a phone
and we needed another way to communicate
when we were teenagers the best way to
talk to our friends after school was MSN
Messenger we had to wait for our mom to
stop using the phone and then we were
able to connect to the internet we all
had the craziest nicknames with the
coolest way to write our names too many
emojis and a random quote and we weren't
happy when we saw that someone copied
our nickname we usually talk to our best
friends but we were really happy to have
our crush in our contact list and we
didn't even talk to them we were too shy
to make the first step instead we just
kept signing in and out so they could
notice us when we finally had the
courage to talk to this boy or girl we
liked we pretended that it was the wrong
conversation or that our friend did it
for fun and then we had to ask our
friend if our crush was online because
we were worried they blocked us do you
remember doing any of these tell us what
the funniest nickname you used on MSN
was Nintendo 64 we are now able to
control video game characters with our
movements dance with our friends in
front of the TV and even discover a new
world in virtual reality no matter what
is coming next the best games we played
were on the Nintendo 64 but first we had
to get on our knees and blow on the
cartridges to make them work if it
worked the first time we were really
lucky if not we had to blow on them
again we never knew how it would be a
good idea but everyone's cousin told
them to do that this console was also
impossible to break now you look at an
Xbox one and it explodes in the 90s you
dropped a television on a Nintendo 64
and the console didn't even care we also
had the best video games we could ever
play we all had our favorite character
in Super Smash Bros
and Mario Kart we played with our
siblings after school and we were really
proud to beat them at this game and
don't forget the Legend of Zelda Donkey
Kong and Yoshi's Story but the best
video game in the world was super mario
64 we just had to jump in one of the
paintings in the castle and we had the
best childhood ever if there is one
thing we would like to keep nowadays
it's the Nintendo 64 pencils as adults
we have to use black or blue pens and if
we don't our college teacher or our boss
won't be happy to see this but in our
childhood we had the best pencils ever
we begged our mom to buy us the funniest
school supplies we could find so we
could be one of the most popular kids in
the class one of them was the pen with
ten different colors we would pick any
color we want to take notes in class and
we have to admit that we all tried
pushing every color at the same time
another thing we loved was milky gel
rollers it just looked so pretty and we
were jealous when a girl in her class
had more milky gel pens than us so we
competed against her by asking her mom
to buy Mr sketch magic markers they all
smelled like different kinds of food we
knew we would get a lot of attention
from it because all the other kids
wanted to smell them but when we wanted
something practical
we used the push pencils they were the
ancestors of the mechanical pencils
unfortunately as soon as we lost some of
these little things we couldn't get our
favourite pencils anymore if only our
pencil cases could be filled with all
these magical school supplies once again
game boys nowadays everyone can play
video games on their cell phones we have
hundreds of choices to download for free
and there's always a popular new game to
be addicted to it's like we're taking
things for granted but in the 90s a Game
Boy was on everyone's Christmas list and
the main reason why we wanted this
little gadget was not Mario Zelda or
Tetris we all wanted to be the very best
like no one ever was every 90s kid
wanted to play Pokemon Pokemon go was so
popular in 2016 but we know that the
real Pokemon trainers have been catching
them all since 1996 and when we felt
like our parents didn't love us enough
to buy a gameboy we played with pokemon
cards instead 90s kids spent their
entire pocket money trying to collect as
many pokemon cards as possible but do
you member one thing our game boys could
do that is popular today we were really
ahead of our time in the night
90s it was possible to take selfies with
the Game Boy camera we were so impressed
by these tiny black and white heavily
pixelated images our face was barely
recognizable but hey we had to start
somewhere maybe that's why we're all so
good at taking pictures of ourselves
nowadays Windows 95 we never like
updates on our computer it takes so much
time to download and we feel like the
version we used before was better but
when we look at Windows 95 we understand
that these updates were for the best
this technology was new to all of us and
we needed a video guide to understand
what is now so intuitive but not any
video guide a VHS with Jennifer Aniston
and Matthew Perry from the TV show
friends and when we just didn't have
time to watch this the friendly paper
clip named Clippy was there to help us
sometimes he just popped up for no
reason at all no matter what we were
always happy to see Clippy because he
was kinda cute and also because there
were so many strange and unexpected
errors on Windows 95 computers were
supposed to be intelligent but that's
what made them so complicated and they
were kind of slow nowadays we can easily
watch movies in streaming all day but in
the 90s it seemed like it took 39 years
to download one song that's a thing we
want to leave in the past but if there
is something we wish we could still have
now it's the screen saver we would like
to see the maze again just for the
nostalgia VHS now there is enough place
on one little DVD for our favorite film
in 10 different languages the special
features and games and we don't even
need that anymore as we can find more
movies than we could ever watch in a
lifetime online but in the 90s we had to
go to Blockbuster to rent our favorite
films every week and watching them was
really different than it is nowadays
there was a different VHS for every
language so you wanted to make sure you
rented the right one or you wouldn't
understand anything you also had to
rewind them after watching it and we
weren't happy when the previous customer
didn't do it because we had to wait 10
minutes before watching our film but
there are so many things that were
better with a VHS we could easily skip
the previews if we didn't want to watch
them even though we didn't use the VHS
for 15 years it remembered where we left
off and it didn't wake us up with loud
repetitive menus when we fell asleep in
front of the TV don't forget the orange
VHS we were so happy to find one
fortunately we still
of a friend who keeps all their VHS
Disney Princess movies watching them
together is the best way to have fun at
a pajama party even now that we are
grownups pencil sharpeners now that
we're studying in college or working
most of us use pens and we don't want to
go back to the time when we had to
sharpen our pencils we all remember that
one embarrassing moment when we forgot
our personal pencil sharpener so we had
to use the one that was mounted on the
wall in class it made so much noise and
we were standing there in front of the
class as everyone was watching us it
felt like a tiny person was hidden
inside and just used the noisy chainsaw
to sharpen our pencils and it was a
knuckle destroyer - this was a moment
any shy kid feared so much we didn't
want to be the one using it when
everyone was silent we just waited for
the break or for someone to use it first
so we wouldn't be the only one sometimes
we were just too shy to stand up and we
just stayed at our desk with a pencil we
couldn't use but one thing was fun with
these pencils the shorter they were the
cooler they were we tried to do the same
thing with erasers but we just kept
losing them did anyone else really use
an entire eraser we don't think it was
even possible cassettes we don't even
use CDs anymore now all the music we can
listen to is either on our cell phone or
simply streaming online but there was a
time when music didn't come for free and
we really appreciated the little things
we had we know how precious our audio
cassettes were because the tape
constantly came out of it or maybe we
were the one responsible for that anyway
we had to fix that problem
kids these days will never truly
understand the link between a cassette
and a pencil we had to put the pencil in
the hole of the audio cassette and turn
it to the tape would go back in place
and it was not the only problem we had
remember when you wanted to listen to
your favorite Spice Girls cassette but
accidentally press the record button
instead oh my gosh our music was gone
forever at least we had our yellow
Walkmans following us everywhere some of
them were even waterproof as if swimming
in a pool wasn't already fun enough huh
but then we grew up and discovered new
technologies the first iPod was not
there yet but we enjoyed the hit clips
music players each cartridge could only
play one song but we were so popular
when we owned one if only we could still
appreciate the value of music like we
did before and that's it for 10 pictures
that will make you feel oh
if you were a 90s kid don't be shy to
tell us about your best memories from
your childhood make sure to give us a
big thumbs up if you owned any of the
objects and don't forget to subscribe to
the things for more videos like this
thanks for watching and bye bye
[Music]